en el 2030 todo el contenido educativo
vinculado a la educación formal
se encontrará de fácil acceso sino es
que gratuito en internet
esto derivado de los objetivos del
milenio generados por la onu para el
2030 y a raíz del acuerdo de la unesco
de que el internet es un derecho humano
para todos
y esto me lleva a una pregunta
es acaso que la educación se
transformará en un futuro debido a que
el acceso a la información estará para
todos
para poder contestar esta pregunta me
parece que es importante hablar también
de la tecnología porque es un hecho que
está muy ligado a la educación
nos encontramos actualmente los dineros
de la cuarta revolución industrial y si
es la cuarta pues al final de cuentas
hubo una primera que empezó con la
vaporización las máquinas que se
convirtieron en la industrialización de
la humanidad
la segunda revolución industrial tuvo
que ver con este tema de la electricidad
definitivamente nos cambio el mundo y
hoy estamos muy acostumbrados a ella
la tercera revolución industrial fue el
siglo pasado y tuvo que ver con la
programación los códigos la computación
y todos los sistemas que al día de hoy
convivimos con ellos
pero la cuarta revolución industrial
está vinculada con la inteligencia
artificial con la robotización y eso
significa que hay un panorama muy
interesante para este futuro cercano
les platico que desde el 2015 en el foro
económico mundial donde se reúnen los
líderes de los países más importantes
del mundo han puesto en la mesa este
debate
cuáles serán los efectos de la cuarta
revolución industrial en un futuro
cercano bajo una premisa piense
toda aquella actividad laboral que hoy
es repetible será sustituida por la
robotización será sustituida por la
tecnología piense en todos aquellos
trabajos que hoy serán sustituidos
entonces bajo esta premisa
en esa mesa hay dos tipos de personas
los líderes que piensan que esto
significa un escenario desolador que
vamos a perder millones de empleos que
vamos a tener un panorama gris
y por el otro lado hay algunos de estos
líderes y yo coincido con ellos que este
también es un panorama que nos brinda
grandes oportunidades que nos brinda
esperanza porque piénsenlo así voy a
hablar de uno de esos empleos que
desaparecerán están en una tienda
departamental se forman y del otro lado
está alguien que recibe el producto lo
pasa sobre el código de barras en la
pantalla aparece el costo y te cobra ya
estará muy de él o de ella si lo hace de
buena cara o de mala gana estamos de
acuerdo pero esa actividad que todos los
días las vemos en muchas tiendas será
sustituida por la robotización es acaso
que los seres humanos fuimos creados
para ese tipo de trabajos
otro de los tips es que todas estas
plataformas digitales para la
transportación individual hoy están
trabajando para convertir lo más pronto
posible esos coches en autónomos que
significa que no haya un chófer mientras
tú te estarás transportando
eso es lo que aspiramos como humanidad
manejar todo el día
y entonces esto me lleva al gran punto
hay que enfrentar como bien lo dice ahí
nuestra nueva realidad y esta nueva
realidad ahora sí está vinculada con la
educación estamos preparando y estamos
educando a las generaciones del futuro
para estas nuevas realidades
yo creo que podríamos empezarlo a
decidir y para ello vale la pena
explicar esta imagen que aparece en
pantalla es una gráfica y para los que
saben es una gráfica de cálculo porque
no soy profesor no y este cálculo
significa el punto de inflexión como
pueden ver hay una trayectoria en el
tiempo y el punto amarillo que ven en el
centro significa determinar la curva de
manera positiva o negativa
este es el momento histórico de la
educación en la que como humanidad
tendremos que decidir qué queremos para
la educación mejorarla o tal vez dejar
que la tecnología sustituya todo
y recordando un poco qué significa
educación piensen en su mente intenten
describir la palabra educación como la
definiría en sus propias palabras es
algo que siempre le digo a mis alumnos
en tus propias palabras no vayas a
wikipedia no vayas a internet inténtalo
definir con tus propias palabras
y quiero remitirme mientras tú piensas
en eso en estas raíces etimológicas
educar y educar educar es significa
hacia donde quiere decir conducir guiar
orientar a la persona y edu que quiere
decir hacer salir extraer sacar lo mejor
de cada una de las personas y si yo tomo
en cuenta estas definiciones de
educación entonces la tecnología no
sustituirá a la pedagogía esto es algo
muy importante siempre será necesario el
factor humano para lo que fuimos creados
innovar motivar e inspirar escuchar al
otro desarrollar cosas nuevas para el
futuro para eso sí fuimos creados para
hacer cosas repetitivas ya dejémoslo a
la robotización pero para escuchar
enamorar convencer para eso si es un
futuro que tenemos que preparar a
nuestras generaciones futuras
y es un hecho que la humanidad hay una
frase muy importante somos más fuertes
en la adversidad y lo hemos visto en
estos últimos meses y además lo hemos
visto en la historia de la humanidad
siempre que surge un problema global
como humanidad hemos sabido y aprendido
a resolverlo hemos sabido y aprendido a
enfrentar
me da mucha esperanza a mí pensar que si
así como hemos combatido un virus a
nivel global presidentes de naciones
organizaciones internacionales y las
personas junto con las instituciones
entonces ahora si se da un panorama
esperanzador para resolver el cambio
climático la pobreza la falta de
alimentos en el mundo me parece que hoy
tenemos y hemos puesto la prueba de que
si se puede
pero es importante entender que en
cuestión de educación volvamos a la
esencia de nuestra humanidad porque la
educación tiene que ver con esta
inspiración y este contacto esta
interacción entre humanos vamos la
educación es el contacto de uno a uno
profesor alumno siempre estará ahí el
profesor presente pero el estudiante
aparecerá cuando decide aprender y por
ello quiero hablarles desde las tres
perspectivas que es importante entender
de la educación
la primera padres de familia la segunda
estudiantes y la tercera profesores
si tú eres un padre de familia es
importante que sepas que en cuestión de
educación para el futuro
no desaproveches la oportunidad de
acompañar a tus hijos desde casa en este
proceso de desarrollo
ahora que tuvimos la oportunidad de que
todos los chamacos se conectaban desde
casa muchos papás no yo ya quiero que se
vayan a la escuela y tal no dejes de
aprovechar la oportunidad de disfrutar
el desarrollo día con día de tus hijos
no importa qué edad tengan
esto es algo muy valioso que no se
repetirá
a los estudiantes les quisiera decir que
hoy tenemos que entender que ustedes son
prácticamente los principales
responsables y los principales actores
de su propia educación aspiramos a cada
vez una educación más autónoma y para
ello ustedes como estudiantes tendrán
que decidir si si quieren ser el autor
principal de sus vidas
o no
y teniendo estas dos cosas en cuenta
ahora quisiera hablarle un poquito más a
los profesores hoy tenemos la gran
oportunidad de dejar de esos profesores
que le hablan más al pizarrón que a los
estudiantes tenemos la gran oportunidad
de convertir en nuestras aulas en lugar
de un auditor en donde todos están
viendo me al sabelotodo y de ese lado
del otro lado están los abel o nada
hoy el profesor como decía la definición
tiene la gran oportunidad de convertirse
en un acompañante en un detonador de
ideas en un cuestionador e imaginando un
aula en donde en lugar de que los
pupitres se estén viendo hacia el frente
ahora estén viéndose entre ellos en
parejas en debate la mitad contra la
otra mitad detonando ideas provocando la
conversación entre ellos y yo como
profesor
simplemente acompañándome asegurando que
los chicos no se están perdiendo en la
conversación
verificando que están cada uno de ellos
aprendiendo y no importa que sea en
matemáticas y en matemáticas el
verdadero arte no está en decir la
fórmula es bien rápido encontrarla en
internet el verdadero arte de enseñar
matemáticas está en detectar al chico
que es muy bueno en matemáticas ya el
chico que es muy malo en matemáticas
siempre habrá en los salones de clases
estos dos
y arte de enseñar será como diseño
estrategias para el que le sabe y
retarlo un poco más y como diseño
estrategias para el que le cuesta
trabajo y que no se sienta frustrado en
el camino ese es el verdadero arte de
enseñar la educación del futuro que
queremos preparar desde hoy
con esto en mente
es tiempo de empezar a soñar es tiempo
de empezar a visualizar un futuro en
donde la educación es un factor super
importante de un nuevo desarrollo de la
humanidad y para hablar de ese futuro yo
quiero hablarles de mi pasado porque
cuando yo tenía cinco o seis siete años
recuerdo en mi cuarto de primaria estaba
una maestra la maestra emma a la que yo
le decía es que en mi casa me dicen que
yo soy malísimo para escribir bonita
letra porque soy zurdo el único es uno
de la familia y entonces pues bueno no
culturalmente dicen que somos malísimos
y ella me dijo unas palabras que hoy
todavía recuerdo si tú decides hacer una
letra perfecta la vas a lograr y hoy
conservo con mucho cariño esta libreta
en donde ahí no se ve padrísima mi letra
desde cuarto de primaria
posteriormente en secundaria tengo un
hermano que de verdad es un año menor
que yo y es buenísimo en fútbol es nato
tiene habilidades natas
y yo siempre dije yo quisiera ser igual
de bueno que mi hermano y llegó un
profesor que me dijo esteban si tú
quieres ser igual de bueno tienes que
estar dispuesto a pagar el precio y eso
significa entrenar todos los días no hay
espacio de descanso para ti
y hoy recuerdo con mucho cariño al
profesor benjamín con el cual fuimos
juntos a representar a méxico en un
torneo de fútbol internacional en
paraguay y que bueno regresamos
campeones es una experiencia que nunca
se me olvidará y que fue gracias al
profesor vengan
y así como él ha habido muchos otros que
han aparecido en mi vida y que se han
convertido ya lo platicábamos hace un
rato en ese punto de inflexión para mí
que mientras yo no veía tanto potencial
en el mí él si se puso junto a mí me
dijo yo veo algo más grande en ti aunque
tú no lo veas
ese es el verdadero papel del profesor
ese es el verdadero papel de todos los
educadores en el mundo
porque de ahí despertaremos y yo estoy
muy seguro nuevas profesiones nuevos
empleos que padre pensar que hoy podemos
dedicarnos a cosas más humanas y
dejarnos de dedicar a cosas menos
humanas o más inhumanas
porque si lo piensan el amor es una de
esas cosas pues que no se ve en las
calles pero una máquina no puede
trabajar por amor una máquina no te
puede enseñar por amor una máquina no se
compromete contigo simplemente repite el
contenido pero otro ser humano si otro
ser humano puede encargarse
comprometerse ir hasta las últimas con
tecos consecuencias por ti
así que este tiempo de soñar nos lleva a
este gran momento de inflexión
es nuestro momento de transformar padres
de familia estudiantes educadores e
instituciones educativas podemos seguir
tomando la decisión de mejorar por este
futuro desde mi perspectiva prometedor y
si a mí me preguntan en mis propias
palabras qué significa educación
yo quisiera concluir diciéndoles que
para mí significa trascender
trascender a través de otras personas
porque a veces en esta profesión cuando
uno es maestro es un poquito ingrato
porque ahora yo me dado cuenta de lo
valioso que han sido estos profesores
para mí y tal vez en ese momento cuando
era morrito no me había dado cuenta y no
les agradecí de manera oportuna y hoy me
gustaría decirles a esos profesores que
se convirtieron en mi punto de inflexión
en agradecerles porque gracias a ellos
hoy yo he tomado la decisión de también
a través de la educación trascender
y qué mejor ejemplo que a través de
estos alumnos les comparto que en los
últimos meses del año pasado en un salón
virtual digital en una videollamada
estaba yo retando a algunos alumnos a
que reflexionáramos solo sobre la
pandemia que estábamos pasando
porque lo que les decía es que lo peor
que nos podría pasar es no aprender de
ella
y entonces les pedí que en un documento
colaborativo en línea todo el mundo
escribiremos estas reflexiones que
habíamos aprendido
y lo que se convirtió en texto empezó a
sonar como líneas y estas líneas se
convirtieron en versos y cuando ya vimos
que eran versos le pusimos música porque
no y esta música se convirtió en una
canción que hoy se encuentra en todas
las plataformas digitales de música que
les recomiendo que escuchen porque son
parte de estas frases que he venido
diciendo hace un rato somos más fuertes
en la adversidad es nuestro momento de
transformar sin dejar de soñar muchas
gracias